we read a real uh fun article about palm
beach um
all roads lead to mar-a-lago inside the
fury and fantasy of donald trump's
florida you've got you've got a fun crew
down there i mean
let's separate this from ideology for a
minute i know the audience is incapable
of doing that
you know i i i don't understand it's
probably because they have nothing going
on in their lives that brings them any
enjoyment but
separating ideology for a minute it's
just a fun crew
roger stone tucker sean hannity ben
shapiro laura ingram ann coulter
brad parskal the trump campaign manager
who's now advising caitlyn jenner the
epicenter of the american conservative
movement has become florida
it's become this swamp of
of um you know
goons and scoundrels and grifters and
just
all-around fun people
tabloid culture tabloid culture the
birthplace of the the national enquirer
and matt drudge lives down there the
drudge report which i love and
conservatism was kept out of
these mainstream institutions for a long
time you know
a lot of the major papers
in america
and uh television networks
were cosmopolitan in the sense that they
were never hard left for sure they were
liberal they were decidedly liberal on a
lot of the key values that conservatives
find themselves on the other side of
and
that's why
a lot of the conservative personalities
in media
are a bit flashier because they uh
they're rappers essentially they they
they talk [ __ ]
they're not getting published in
mainstream places right so they had to
take over alternative media talk radio
and the internet and people like rush
limbaugh and matt drudge and ann coulter
and they came
from outside
of this uh
system where you played these
respectability politics and these guys
like christopher ruddy you started
newsmax and they're all down there in
palm beach florida
and it it just seems like a lot of fun
it seems like a lot of fun and if you
read this vanity fair article like the
the waiter who's serving roger stone and
laura loomer
uh food
it goes like this so they're seated in a
private room a heavy set waiter comes in
an immigrant from yugoslavia named mario
who introduces himself as a die-hard
republican he's crestfallen he sees
laura loomer and
uh
you know roger stone sitting there and
he goes unbelievable what they did to us
and loomer goes i know and the waiter
goes bunch of criminals and stoned
oliver stone goes not over yet
and then mario goes that's right i'm
hoping we're all hoping
so they're keeping that hope alive down
there in florida
it's like you know the song the
beginning of portlandia the dream of the
90s is alive in portland
that's what's going on and
the dream of q is alive and palm beach
you know
and it's just these people just kind of
dancing around eating steaks and
martinis at 3 p.m
thinking that trump's going to be
reinstalled as president somehow fat
mario the waiter laura loomer
ann coulter who then at the end of the
article ann coulter and matt trudge go
we're leaving florida and we're not
telling anybody where we're going
and i guess they're leaving because uh
judge and i are both leaving florida and
we're not telling anyone where we're
going this time
um i guess because coulter had she's
fallen out of the trump camp
she's unhappy with trump
but it's fun florida's always kind of
been a fun place and and i remember when
we snuck into the breakers buffet yes
and there's something nice about florida
there's something distinctly american
about lying your way
into an all-you-can-eat mother's day
buffet without a mother
we had no mother we honored no one it
was just to sit there and feed ourselves
on shellfish and it was great and saguru
was there but we didn't even see him we
didn't see him yeah
but that's uh that's florida for you
it's a fun article in vanity fair if you
read it and uh
the i mean the thing is
you know ben said i'd love to go to one
of these parties earlier
and you would and you wouldn't
because one thing i learned
um when i was debating people that were
to become people like this right
a lot of the kids that i was debating
when i was in college and even though i
was at a community college many of these
people were going on to four-year
schools and
uh they were going to i think one of
them worked for mitt romney for a while
the thing about people who live sleep
eat and breathe politics is that
they're boring
the thing about politics is
it obscures many of the truths of life
which are
truly
apolitical right the deep human truths
of life
which is what art tries to get to which
is why art sucks now because we're
fitting those truths or showcasing them
in a way that has to break down into
this political binary it's not natural
but
and i'm not saying artists are fun to be
around either don't don't mistake me but
the thing about people whose entire life
their entire existence the way they
interface with the world is all politics
is deeply unfulfilling it's deeply
unfulfilling
and many of them know that
um
because there is a
disconnect
between
what you're saying
and what's happening
and that's a chasm
meaning you're not really in the fight
to change things as much as you're in
the fight
to become
famous or wealthy
and
you're really trying to establish
yourself
and then there's this movement of people
that you can
kind of grab on to for a minute and you
could guide them or push them
in a certain way but that's an unruly
mob of human beings that's just gonna go
somewhere else or you gotta keep track
of them keep hold of them it's not easy
and you know
real change is very difficult
and it's not that glamorous and the
people that work to make real change
like real activists lawyers and doctors
and people that give up lucrative
careers to then go help people on the
street and actually help people get
elected to local uh government and
change laws that affect people's lives
that's very different than the pundit
class who's swilling
you know gin martinis at 3 a.m at the
breakers in palm beach and talking about
revolution and this is happening and
this has hap and none of it's really
happening that's the thing i mean it's
not really
happening and and the people that do
this kind of know that but they've given
themselves over to it and their entire
life is politics there's not much else
there
and it's why i decided to get out you
know i thought i wanted to be in that
world and i said i don't want to be in
the world i don't have to have an idea
or a thought and go wait a minute
is this
is this something that my enemies would
say
or is this something my allies would say
and and
then what
i didn't want to have to put everything
through that prism
but if i did it does seem fun
to do it in in palm beach florida
with these lunatics they seem a lot more
fun
than the neoliberal hampton sat and the
brooklyn socialists said these people
seem a lot more fun if we're just gonna
go off fun
if we're just gonna go off fun
martinis with these lunatics
i mean
the true answer is none of the above
but if you had to
it might be here